do you think he would say that he never
lost that feeling for you that he just
loved you
through whatever phase you were going
through he definitely tells me that all
the time yeah yeah
ryan dorsey has broken his silence for
the first time
since the death of his late ex-wife nya
rivera
he was just he was kind of always the
one ryan took to instagram
in a lengthy post on saturday saying in
part
quote this is so unfair there's not
enough words to express
the hole left in everyone's hearts i
can't believe this is life now
i don't know if i'll ever believe it the
actor went on to recall his final
moments with
naya saying quote you were just here
we were just in the back swimming with
josie the day before
life just isn't fair i don't know what
to say
i'm thankful for our times and our
journey that brought us together and
gave us the sweetest
and kindest smart little boy we could
ever hope for
ryan continued by saying quote life is
all about good
times and bad times but with josie it
makes the bad a little less so
because a part of you will always be
with us
he'll never forget where he came from we
miss you
we will always love you he ended his
post by thanking
everyone who has supported their family
during this tragic time
and shared a reminder for us all saying
quote
hold your loved ones close and cherish
the times you have
with those you care about nya and ryan
were married from 2014
to 2018 and share a four-year-old son
named josie together you love being a
mommy oh my gosh
josie was found alone on a boat on lake
pairu in ventura county california
when naya went missing on july 8. the 33
year old actress's body was recovered
from the lake on july
13th and during a news conference that
afternoon
the ventura county sheriff department
shared the working theory of what
may have happened the day she went
missing the idea
perhaps being that the boat started
drifting it was unanchored
and that she mustered enough energy to
get her son back onto the boat
but not enough to save herself
[Music]
just hours after naya's ex-husband ryan
took to instagram nya's younger sister
nakayla rivera broke her silence for the
first time
as well she paid tribute to her sister
on instagram by writing in part
quote i've never known a life without
you in it
and still can't imagine it my world is
turned upside down
but through it all everything we were we
are
still i'll always look at you with the
same eyes as i did when i was young
she added quote i'll love you for
eternity
and miss you every second of my life
you